intentionally or unintentionally people
who are being led to believe that
indulgences in pain for their sins in
some monetary way or through works was
how they were going to gain salvation
and that completely maligned the process
of Christ and Martin Luther raise
awareness about that and for that I'm
extremely think there is I will I will
grant he did change over time but he did
change over time so earlier on he was a
little bit better more of a reformer
than late later on all of the
anti-semitic comments came later in his
life they weren't they didn't come
earlier in his life however let's not
forget that he did add that first Sola
that only faith from Romans he added
that and and in subsequent translations
if it was of course Ali be a little bit
holier act a little bit better if that
was the case you would have been totally
fine with the Pharisees because the
Pharisees were the holiest of them all
but obviously it wasn't about works it
was about faith of course but I think
it's a straw man I don't see anywhere in
church teaching where the Catholic
Church has ever taught that through
works you will earn your salvation the
church explicitly didn't call that a
heresy that's the heresy of Pelagius in
the 4th or 5th century v and we do know
i'm certain of course Christ's sacrifice
was perfect but let's not forget that
that Christ says to Peter Peter you are
this your Arak on this rock I'll build
my church
here are the keys to the kingdom of
heaven whatever you loose on earth will
be loosed in heaven whatever you bind on
earth will be bound in heaven he also
said there will be many who come to me
and say Lord Lord who will not see the
kingdom of heaven and of course James
says faith without works is dead
actually will not enter the kingdom of
heaven because what Martin Luther did if
she said this is not about your external
proof of what
you are saved or not this is about your
heart and I'm not saying the entirety of
the Catholic faith faith preaches
otherwise but he felt where he was that
that was the trend that was going on at
least the people in the Catholic Church
we're starting to focus too much on the
outer works and not enough on true
repentance in their heart and that's
exactly what Martin Luther came to
refocus the church on was focusing on
the heart transformation that grace
through faith actually accomplishes
because you're right faith without works
is dead but works without faith is
nothing sure what the when is the
Catholic Church ever taught otherwise
when does the Catholic Church ever
taught that you'll earn your way to
heaven through works I don't I don't
deny that there were corrupt
professional partners obviously as many
Pope's condemned them explicitly but if
Martin Luther's problem was with some
local bishops and some local priests
selling heaven they were trying to sell
heaven to ignorant people then then
that's a political conversation that's
not a theologist refuge how he just said
that the the issue is the issue is
instead of saying okay Luther Martin
Luther we'll look this over we'll talk
about this he was persecuted for coming
to his art archbishop and saying these
things he was brought and told to say
mayor Copa before him and instead of and
instead of doing that he stood his
ground and of course like as you said
years later he seemed to become a little
bit embittered but let's not forget
that's a statement sure yeah well as my
as I'm saying you know it was because
Catholic mobs attacked his followers and
and burned them at the stake and stoned
them well if anybody was a proponent of
burning at the stake I think we would
all agree that Martin Luther was a was a
proponent sure and I'm not gonna defend
Martin Luther in his entirety after all
if there was one thing Catholics and
Protestants were united and it was the
persecution of the early evangelicals of
course they weren't called that back
then but you know that exactly what alia
said it's more about bye-bye faith alone
and standing up to the corruption of his
day you know I will bring up this point
though because I am sympathetic to a lot
of these poor Protestant arguments and I
do like a lot of Protestant theologians
and apologists but it there is this one
sticking point because the the question
here especially with Luther is is the
church the church
is the Pope in the Petrine line in the
line of Peter and did Christ Institute a
real church on earth
with a real clergy and real buildings
and real windows in real places or is it
a strictly an ethereal sort of thing
that floats about and does not have real
clergy and real windows and things like
that and it just seems to me that you
know in a religion which is based on a
fact it's not based on a philosophy it's
based on a fact the incarnation of the
Divine logos into a particular person in
through a particular mother in a
particular place in a particular time
where he performed particularly Racal
Zinn space and time on real people and
then literally was killed by someone
named Pontius Pilate and then was a
literally resurrected stayed around for
six weeks and then ascended into heaven
that it makes sense to me that that guy
would have picked twelve real people to
be the apostles and when he said I
establish a church would have
established a real institution on earth
it's it's hard for me to get beyond that
and to think that really there was
there's a there's all fact a unity of
the symbol and the symbolized of the
logos and the Creator in the creation
but then it just becomes if you're real
after that